foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
thank you
Wednesday Wednesday
we were supposed to have a hearing today
but we do not because of hurricane Ian
Things Are
getting dangerous down in Florida
the most dangerous thing is probably for
about this hurricane in Florida that
we're going to see
is the response that the fascist
Governor will have down there I'm sure
with the attitude that he has how he
ostracizes people that he will
absolutely I think Texas Paul tweeted
dollars to Donuts this guy's gonna try
to make everything about this hurricane
someone else's fault other than his
response
it's probably about right um knowing Ron
DeSantis uh this is why it is so
important folks to elect leaders who are
serious
when you have serious events like this
in Florida where we have a storm bearing
down on the citizens of the United
States and people who not just citizens
but also people who are here
it is
um you know it's a human thing
this is Natural Things uh
with the storm this happens every year
with climate change they are getting
worse and worse and I guess someone
this morning on on CNN said you can't
blame this on climate change one event
yeah well you can't blame one event on
climate change but you can blame the
escalation
the escalation of the climate changing
on global warming you most certainly can
do that the science shows it
we can do that
but in Florida there are hurricanes we
know this
we know this
and this is why it is so important for
people to participate in democracy
because as much as we can't stop a
hurricane from happening
in any given moment
we can absolutely have
the best leadership possible
and if anyone thinks that Ron DeSantis
is the leadership that you'd want in A
Moment Like This well
[ __ ] around and we're going to find out
because we're going to find out really
soon how he's going to absolutely play
politics with these people's lives just
like he's played politics
with the lives of migrants
if you have any question in your mind
rather he's willing to treat other human
beings in a certain way all you have to
do is look at his history
and you say Tony Jesus Christ you're
politicizing this issue at the very
start I'm not politicizing it well I
mean I guess I am but the problem is the
problem is is elections do have
consequences they absolutely have
consequences we know that from 2016.
we know that
we know the pandemic response would have
been completely different if we had had
serious people
in leadership positions
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis and Greg
Abbott are not serious people
they're not serious
anyone who cheers when you use human
beings
refugees seeking Asylum legal asylum in
this country as political pawns and meat
basically not as humans you dehumanize
them all the way down to the Core
you don't believe that Ron DeSantis is
going to pick and choose who he helps in
Florida
you don't believe that
really
what evidence do you have that Ron
DeSantis isn't going to totally botch
this response to this hurricane
what gives you the evidence
now I hope all Floridians stay safe even
the ones who
wrongly support a governor who is going
to absolutely botch this response I
don't even need proof yet to know that
Rhonda santis is going to botch this
response here
I don't need it we'll have it doubt me
doubt me
this is the craziest [ __ ] thing I've
ever seen in my life when this happens
is because not only is he going to be
begging begging
and behind closed doors for federal
response which they're already getting
but in in public the guy's gonna be
talking about how Joe Biden's federal
government because we're a red State
he's not doing this and he's not doing
that which will all be a 100 complete
[ __ ] lies
complete [ __ ] lies
do you remember
there was a hurricane in New Jersey
when Chris Christie was governor
and there was a big
hoopla
about Barack Obama going and Chris
Christie being an adult
Chris Kirsty was an adult and worked
with the president of the United States
even though he was his enemy I guess
you'd say
in today's political climate that's what
he would be called
but he worked with the president United
States and the federal Administration
to get New Jersey back on their feet
and he was he was ostracized Chris
Christie
because he appeared in a picture with
Obama
where they were trying to help American
citizens which is their [ __ ] job it's
their [ __ ] job
that's what we [ __ ] hire them to do
almost more than anything
but you can even go back a little
further than that to remember that the
guy running against Ron DeSantis
Charlie Crist appeared on stage with
Obama the same [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
thanked him thanked Obama for the
federal response because the Obama
Administration was prompting their
response
and it's what led us to where we're at
today where this election is between
Charlie Chris the Democrat
and Ron DeSantis
the fascist
listen folks this our elections and our
democracy is if there's more at stake
than just
then rather Rhonda Santos is going to be
a fascist and banned books
these people are willing to use federal
funds to ship human beings in a place
where it's going to be hard for them to
continue to seek legal Asylum that's the
purpose
it's to own the libs and to kill their
opportunity to seek legal asylum in in
the courts
and I hope all Floridians stay safe here
again
even the ones who have the Rhonda santis
and Trump signs in their yards
because at the end of the day none of us
can help that the storm is coming
Floridians can't you know just say ah
you know let's wait for the storm till
next week I mean they even canceled the
January 6 select hearing to make sure
that the the response was prompt
to make sure all human resources went to
the storm
that's the purpose
is to not to distract from the most
important thing right now for Floridians
to say stay safe
which Rhonda Santos has done the bare
minimum there of coming out and and
briefing Floridians on what to do and
what not to do
barely
but if you think he's not gonna play
games
with for Floridians lives
and even their Humanity here you have
not been paying attention that is why it
is so [ __ ] important that we elect
people who are serious
like me I would not make a good
politician I get that [ __ ] all the time
you should run for office really with my
[ __ ] mouth you really think that's a
good idea
the way I politicize everything you
think that's a good idea I I'm on the
election end of the politics folks I'm
on the messaging and narrative end
of left-wing Democrat libtard politics
that's where I live
I'm I would not be a good policy maker
that's the that's why I yell and scream
into a microphone
We're All in This Together
this democracy that we have
regardless of what happens
rather rather we have to fight for our
rights
and for other people's rights to their
bodily autonomy the right to not to for
your children to go to school and not
get gunned down by a weapon of War
we're all in this to [ __ ] gather
and when this fascist arm of the
Republican Party takes over
part of our two-party system because
that's what we got folks I don't give a
[ __ ] what you say about third party and
nonsense we have a two-party system that
is what we have
that's what we got
and until that changes that's what
you're going to have to deal with
and the the the problem that we're
having now in this country it's not that
there's two sides
there's one side it's people who are for
democracy fighting against [ __ ]
who want to tear it down and want to
destroy our two-party system and make it
an authoritarian fascist state
they want to tell you what religion you
can and can have they want to tell you
what books you can and can't read
they want they want to [ __ ] tell you
all kinds of [ __ ] about your genitalia
all kinds of [ __ ] about your genitalia
in Tennessee they want to marry your
children
in Texas they want to they want to make
it to where you don't have
authority over your children
they want to take away your consent from
your children away from you and make
[ __ ] criminal in Texas which is
absolutely batshit crazy
they're ready they're ready to take away
people's rights to vote oh just give
them a minute
hell the hell the church that they claim
they love and they claim as the backing
of their nationalism wants to take away
the rights of women to vote
help me just do it I dare you
it's what these people want that's what
they want at their core and the problem
is in Florida
they thought it was a good idea to put
one of these [ __ ] fascists in charge
of the governor's office
and I didn't get time to play it
yesterday but Stacey Abrams gave a talk
about being governor and how much how
much
it is it is how important it is that we
focus on Governor's races how much power
a governor has
because Rhonda santis is going to have
almost absolute power over the federal
funds that is given to him to the State
of Florida here for this disaster
and he is totally gonna [ __ ] that up
and the only reason why I know Ronda
Santos is going to [ __ ] it up because
he's Ron DeSantis
he buys trumpism Hook Line Sinker and
he's going to use these funds as his
political crutch
to try to win an election because he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the people of
Florida doesn't give a [ __ ] about them
he only cares about one thing winning
this governor's race so he can run for
president in 2024. that's all he gives a
[ __ ] about
so that way he can create a fascist
State like he's tried to create in
Florida
across the United States
and that's why he's one of their [ __ ]
Heroes
is because he's a goddamn Nazi
now yesterday we talked with Texas Paul
and I said which is this is the truth
if 10 people are sitting at a table with
one Nazi you got 11 [ __ ] Nazis at the
table that's what you got
now the problem that Florida has right
now
is that the hurricane is coming in
bearing in on them it's going to cause a
lot of damage I I hope that everyone
stays safe
and we can make sure that
we can minimize the tragedy
property can be replaced
we as the people always step in
regardless of if rather it's blue state
or red state they're American states
folks
we always step in as the people
to help out those states that are under
those natural disasters whether it be a
hurricane a flood a tornado and we
should do that that is something we
should do no matter what state no matter
what [ __ ] [ __ ] box Senator or [ __ ]
box governor
but folks it [ __ ] matters it matters
who the governor is in these states
and when you have someone like Ron
DeSantis who could give a [ __ ] less
about human beings
and again you don't have to go very far
to know that this [ __ ] does not
give a [ __ ] about other human beings
doesn't give two [ __ ] he's willing to
probably commit crime
to make them his political meat Pawns
to own the libs
he went to another state
listen to me when I tell you this
Floridians your governor who is not
going to do the response that you
deserve
went to another [ __ ] state
convinced people who were seeking Asylum
here legally from a communist government
right something that should be an easy
talking point for them
coerce them
lied to them defrauded them
to get on a [ __ ] plane and sent them
to another state
after he you know did a photo op in his
state
and spent Florida's money 12 million
bucks I wonder how I wonder how far 12
million dollars would go for Hurricane
Relief
I wonder
240 thousand dollars
for each one of those migrants who came
here seeking legal Asylum to to
to ship them from Texas to Martha's
Vineyard I wonder how far that would go
in Hurricane Relief
and I'm telling you no one else there's
going to be very few people that you're
going to hear in the media it's going to
politicize the [ __ ] out of this like I
am this morning I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ]
I tell you every single day politicize
the ever loving [ __ ] out of everything
Ron DeSantis it's not just bad
for Florida he's bad for America
and the [ __ ] needs to be sent
back underneath the rock that he came
out from underneath
and he is going to botch this response
100
you just [ __ ] hide and watch and
doubt me we're gonna report on it here
I'm gonna talk about it because I
already know that it exists because it's
Ron DeSantis and he doesn't like other
[ __ ] people
he only cares about himself and about
his other fascist supporters and
followers the tail wags the dog down
there in fascist Florida
and the Nazis got a hold of the [ __ ]
tail like a son of a [ __ ]
and if you think if you sit there and
think for a second well Tony Jesus
Christ those people in Florida you're
politicizing the hurricane no well I
mean yeah I'm politicizing the fact that
you have a [ __ ] Governor gonna do a [ __ ]
job because he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
Floridians that's the point that's the
[ __ ] point
Kemp in Georgia doesn't give a [ __ ]
about Georgians I don't care what he
tries to frame up what he tries to sell
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about them he
doesn't want him to even vote in Georgia
Ron DeSantis doesn't want children to go
to Book Fairs and read books in Florida
he's shipping he's shipping legal Asylum
Seekers as pieces of meat to own the
libs
you have Greg Abbott another [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] governor who's doing the
exact same thing we talked about it
yesterday with Texas Paul
the [ __ ] spending billions with
a [ __ ] B billions of dollars
in a political stunt to dehumanize
people who were coming here legally
and then taking credit for the fentanyl
being seized at the border
I mean
it's not getting in the country the the
DHS and
and the Biden Administration and our
government that we hire is doing the
jobs trying to stop Fentanyl
from coming across the border
and it's having success the Republicans
are pointing out the success
look how many pounds they've seized yeah
that's that that's the amount that
didn't get through the Border because
it's uh
secure
dumb [ __ ] it's all a lie it's
all gaslighting
and anyone who stands out there and says
oh well there is a border crisis there
is a border crisis it's actually a thing
and the Democrats don't want to talk
about it no Republicans are lying about
it and Democrats aren't going to talk
about the [ __ ] lies they're not going
to defend the lies it's [ __ ] it's
nonsense
just like
just like we're gonna see nonsense with
this hurricane response
100 full stop you hide you watch
and the only reason why is because Ron
DeSantis is in charge
that's it
what what more do you need to know
then Ron DeSantis is in charge of the
hurricane response
what what what more do you want
do you do I need I mean I do 30 minutes
in the beginning of the show
every day
but I could just tweet that and that's
the cause and effect here
so
as you go about your day especially
if you're not Florida if you're in
Florida stay safe
please stay safe do the things that you
need to do to stay safe don't worry
about your property worry about your
life
worry about your family's life your
community lives
stay safe stay healthy
don't do anything that would stupidly
put your life in danger please
and we will try our damnedest
to get out the word that we need to get
someone in charge
come this election that's going to have
a response because folks that's one
thing that's going for Florida right now
is floridines have the ability here
to put a stop to Ron desantis's stupid
[ __ ] response that he's gonna have
you have the option you have the choice
it's called Liberty in this country
you have the ability to go vote for
Charlie Crist the Democrat
who is gonna make mistakes that's gonna
happen it happens
no one is perfect nobody is perfect
but at least at least Charlie Grist has
the decency to treat humans I don't know
like humans
this decency bar that we have the
standard of decency is a really low
[ __ ] bar it really is but at the end
of the day when someone's not even a
decent [ __ ] person and they don't
treat humans with Humanity well you
goddamn know that they shouldn't be in
leadership anywhere anywhere I'm talking
anywhere
they shouldn't be in charge of the
[ __ ] drive-through at the McDonald's
Ron DeSantis should not even be running
a cash register
that's how indecent he is
now he'll be in Republican politics for
a long time because even if and when he
loses this race against Crist
it's probably going to really affect his
ability to run in 2024. he knows that
that's why he's that's why he's trying
to score political points on the backs
of
of migrants coming to this country
seeking legal Asylum from a communist
regime
I don't understand how they can't get
the messaging right it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
because if they supported legal Asylum
from a Communist Regime from a place
like Venezuela that would be them
welcoming brown people and they can't
have their base thinking that they like
brown people like Ron DeSantis can't do
that
he can't even pretend for a minute
to do that
that would turn his base against him
and the tail that Wags the dog would be
super pissed
so as we go through the next few days of
this hurricane
let's support Floridians no matter who
they support
let's support Floridians but let's not
[ __ ] let's not [ __ ] hide the fact
that Ron DeSantis is a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he will totally [ __ ] this up
I mean
again just [ __ ] doubt me I don't know
what to tell you
we're gonna report on it here I'm
telling you
it's gonna happen he's gonna do
something really [ __ ] stupid
and it's gonna happen
thank you everyone for joining us today
I know we were supposed to have a
hearing today and again the hurricane
has affected the entire country but I
tell you we still are bringing on a
special guest today
um I'm so glad he is going to join us
today he's joined us several times he's
always been there at every single one of
these hearings
every single one of these hearings I so
appreciate his political commentary
sometimes we even get on the phone
privately and we'll do like a two-hour
show on the phone
because we love politics so much
and we don't always agree we don't
always agree I'm gonna ask his opinion a
little bit on this riggleman book and I
think we have a little bit of
disagreement on this but I'm going to
ask him about this riggleman book and
what his view of it is
and what his view of the data is
um David Bender is going to join us
David Bender the political commentary
and political strategist I can't wait to
talk to David he was going to join us
for the hearing and I talked to him
yesterday and as when I was on the phone
with David is when they were canceling
the hearing they were postponing I
should say they were postponing the
hearing so we were talking on the phone
as that it was happening and we were
trying to figure out what was going to
happen
um so he said you know what I want to
join you tomorrow anyways because he had
it planned and I said that's great I
would love to have you on the show so we
have David Bender coming up here so
don't don't go anywhere because we have
David Benner but I want to tell all of
you I appreciate we had a seven day
YouTube band
and you guys follow us all over the
Internet and there's people still
watching on Twitch on Facebook
um over on Twitter over on Tony Michaels
dot live and go to Tony Michaels dot
live if you want to watch there every
single day and bookmark that thing in
case we get banned other places or we
get suspended from posting other places
but you can also show support there not
just not just monetary you can give a
tip and we appreciate all the tips that
you give you can give a one-time tip or
you can give a monthly tip where it
automatically does it every single month
because we run here at the Tony Michaels
podcast on your support that is what we
run on and not just the monetary support
but also the likes the shares you guys
going and following us on other
platforms
and watching us on other platforms also
downloading the podcast because we're on
Apple Spotify Google that always helps
so much and we appreciate our entire
audience you are the best audience that
we have
you are the best audience that there is
and I'm not joking you guys followed us
around
it didn't matter you were looking for us
every which way we got so many comments
on YouTube where in the hell were you at
they thought there's no way Tony stop
yelling into a microphone it just that's
not a thing and it isn't it isn't I've
been here every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
and Facebook and I will continue to be
so go follow us Tony Michaels dot live
and if you go there you can actually uh
click the sandwich icon if you want to
give some support you can get a Rhonda
santis can go [ __ ] himself shirt
because he's gonna be in the news a lot
about his failures and no question hide
and watch Ron DeSantis is going to botch
this response to this hurricane I have
no doubt about it and let me tell you
something I believe dark Brandon is
going to come in and have to save him
and also go to store.dtonymichaels.com
and find your exclusive dark Brandon
Tony Michaels design store that Tony
michaels.com so you can get the dark
Brandon
design or you can get the Ron DeSantis
can go [ __ ] himself I did not plan that
as far as like merch and the story here
of Ron DeSantis versus Joe Biden because
that's kind of how it's going to turn
out here because Ron DeSantis is
definitely going to blame everything
that goes wrong
on the federal response and it a hundred
percent a hundred percent is going to be
Ron desantis's problem so we're going to
talk about this on the other side but I
also I also want to ask David Bender
about the January 6 select hearing even
though it didn't happen today and how he
feels about this riggleman book because
we talked yesterday and I think we have
a little bit of disagreement not a lot
but a little bit I want to ask him about
it and Gabe Sanchez is going to join us
as well so everyone stick around don't
go anywhere David bender and the great
co-host Gabe Sanchez right after this
break stick around we'll be right back
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
as always
we deliver great guests here on this
show
great political conversation
we were gonna have David bender on for
the January 6th select hearing anyways
even though it was postponed so I said
David David just just come on the show
and he said yes I went to gum on the
show David Bender welcome to the Tony
Michaels podcast how are you
how are you my friend
I don't think we've got his mic I don't
think his mic is working I'm not sure I
heard I heard the music a moment I did
good to be here there there we go
well we lost him he'll be back he'll be
back Gabe for the board today by the way
oh do you yeah um hurricane DeSantis
probably I don't know okay I'm just
saying we're politicizing the [ __ ] out
of this today you know we do that here
on the Tony Michaels podcast fake Gabe
is really upset about it by the way he's
he's well I mean you know he's heavily
upset that that I'm talking into a
microphone as always
but he thinks that Ron DeSantis is
probably going to do a great job of
making sure that only certain people get
Federal relief here I'm sure I'm sure
that's what they're excited about the
fascist in Florida and the fascist
around the country are really excited
um about
Rhonda Santas more than likely
politicizing the funds that the federal
government's going to give him
so here's here's the uh I've got a I've
got a
I think it was for
I think it was for fake Gabe fake Gabe
was talking about well because we didn't
get to play yesterday because I was like
oh well we're kind of busy and chatting
and stuff so I've got the latest what
was that which I figured we can play uh
if we get David at on a little after
um you know what let's go ahead and play
that all right yeah because we're
waiting on this for fake Gabe
okay yeah if you wanna uh where's the
link for that do you have a link for it
quick yeah or should I look it up
because this what was that it's on J.R
Majewski right this is the guy who who
um decided it would be a good idea to
um
deal Valor and I guess I guess that's
where you're getting at where the um the
fake gate problem here is where he
thinks he doesn't know what stolen vower
is probably
um neither you know and we we kind of
pick on fake game here
um but it's not just fake game
it's not just him and what I mean by
that is that it doesn't matter who it is
in the chat
they're all kind of the same Gabe yeah
oh and what I mean is that that the
opinions and the stuff is kind of like
Cookie Cutter [ __ ] you know it's like q
a on Facebook cookie cutter stuff it's
not really it's not really it doesn't
really make sense much but uh
not stealing my Valor no no no no no
right but but Majewski on the other hand
loves to steal Valor and you actually
bring the receipts I believe in this one
here's the thing I I realized after it I
was like oh I could I could have kept
going like you know when those photos
like okay stop like stop he's he's
already down like there was more stuff
uh how he doesn't like to talk about his
record ever whenever people ask about it
he's always like oh I don't really like
to talk about it because well uh it's it
was stuff that I did over there then you
know I just don't want to divulge that
information
it's right it's all it's it's it's just
complete [ __ ] and it's uh it is
non-stop line you would think that the
Republican Party would be totally okay
with this right like they would totally
love the fact that this guy is a liar
however
we find out that there's some Line in
the Sand they draw
right well I mean well the thing that
they can't do
the thing that they can't do and they
discovered this with January 6 and this
is part of the problem they're having
with it is they can't say one thing like
oh blue lives matter and then beat them
with flagpoles because there's some new
footage out today that I want to show in
the [ __ ] list Roundup of uh the Trump
supporters uh using um not just
flagpoles but using a huge Banner now we
there was a time lapse video that we
actually put on our YouTube channel
it was a while back and it looks like a
big huge trunk Banner like Works its way
through this crowd and it really is
unclear in that timelapse video that
that thing has a big huge metal frame
around it and they were using it as a
battering ram against the guard rails
that were holding holding the
insurrectionist back but in these videos
it makes it very clear that these people
were violently trying to break through
the barriers right the cops the police
were standing to who they back
um when they're not against them you
know it's again it's one of those
moments of like it totally in support
when it benefits me when I'm not the one
on the the other the opposite end which
is the one that's being investigated the
one that's being charged the one that is
being uh in trouble right when it's when
it's not that then I'm totally okay with
the blue right a back to Blue all the
time
all right right well
um it is it is it is something to watch
them and we'll watch that footage in a
bit but this J.R Majewski thing is crazy
someone that commented and they said Jr
Mike majups like majupski like oopsie
oopsie oopski Jr oopsie
um so Amy says here real Gabe has the
most mesmerizing eyes oh wow now you got
a fan and some think I look like
Leonardo and apparently Gabe here has
mesmerizing eyes so come come every day
so much well here's the thing if you're
listening to this on the uh directories
Apple Spotify Google wherever you listen
to this podcast you gotta come over and
look at this guy's mesmerizing eyes I
don't know exactly what Amy's talking
about here I feel like I'm the best
looking one but you know that's just how
it goes I don't know how it goes
ow look at you okay let's
let's go to let's go to what was that
and uh see what we got here look oh the
paused face okay everybody here's what
was that with Gabe Sanchez's newest
version on J.R Majewski hey everyone and
welcome to what was that with Gabe
Sanchez a trump endorsed Q Anon
believing Capital storming
insurrectionist was busted for Stolen
Valor and now the GOP has canceled
nearly one million dollars in ads for
him
[Music]
for those of you who may not know about
J.R Majewski he's a trump endorsed
Republican candidate running for Ohio's
ninth congressional district and to get
a better idea of who he is here's a clip
from his campaign video
gotta kick down doors
well that's just what Patriots do
when I'm elected I won't bow to
establishment pawns or power hungry
radicals I will hold my own and demand
that once again America stands
independent and strong like the country
that I fought for honestly this looks
like every other Republican campaign
video nowadays I mean forget proposing
actual policies to help people in this
country just promote political violence
with guns and boom you're qualified to
hold office and at his core Majewski is
a cunan Believer who has repeatedly
promoted q9 conspiracies on social media
and in interviews I believe in
everything that's been put out from q
and wouldn't you know it Majewski also
stormed the capital on January 6th he
even claimed to have helped organize and
arrange travel for others to get to the
Insurrection but least impressively
Majewski is also an aspiring rapper and
I use the term rapper very loosely
okay I think you get the point let's
move on now some of you may remember
Majewski as the guy who painted his
entire yard as a giant Trump Banner back
in July 2020. this 19 000 square foot
Banner took 120 gallons of biodegradable
paint to create initially Majewski
intended to create a national league of
families pow M.I.A flag before deciding
it would require too much black but
something tells me he's not the biggest
fan of that color he Then followed it up
in September 2021 with a giant mural of
Donald Trump and they say they're not an
occult but majewski's magalon Obsession
actually started back in July 2019. he
painted a 13 star American flag on his
lawn for a veterans fundraiser as a
patriotic way to honor veterans which is
interesting considering that he was just
busted for Stolen Valor now Majewski
describes himself as an Air Force combat
veteran who is deployed to Afghanistan
after for the 9 11 terrorist attacks
Majewski has spoken on several occasions
about his time in Afghanistan like this
time did you serve in Afghanistan yes he
did
how many tours one
what what year were you there what years
uh
2002 2003. or the time he said he was in
operation enduring Freedom you served in
operation enduring Freedom correct
absolutely Afghanistan yes sir or the
time he talked about missing his
grandmother's funeral because he was in
Afghanistan probably is I lost my
grandmother when I was in Afghanistan
and I didn't I didn't get to see her her
funeral now despite majewski's stories
of serving the Associated Press obtained
his military documents and they paint a
very different picture they indicate
Majewski never deployed to Afghanistan
but instead completed a six-month stint
helping to load planes at an air base in
Qatar a long time U.S Ally that is a
safe distance from the fighting and just
for perspective Qatar is over a thousand
miles away from Afghanistan among the
military documents obtained by the AP
was majewski's DD Form 214 which is a
certificate of release or discharge from
active duty it literally says during his
nearly four years of active service
Majewski served zero years zero months
and zero days of Foreign Service so
after the AP story came out Majewski
held a press conference to explain his
side of the story we show one deployment
to Qatar from May 2002 to November 2002.
what he did meaning me
or where he may have went from that
location we do not have visibility on
in fact the orders and the military
records that I've been able to
obtained from my personal files shows
that all of my deployments are listed as
classified wait what was that obtained
from my personal files shows that all of
my deployments are listed as classified
okay this excuse makes zero sense
Majewski is claiming his military
records don't show any evidence of
combat or service in Afghanistan because
they're classified actually you know
what maybe President Biden can just
declassify his military records so we
can finally get to the bottom of this I
mean according to Trump you can
declassify just by saying it's
Declassified even by thinking about it
so then Majewski tweeted out two
documents to prove he wasn't lying and
that was the moment when political
consultant and army veteran Fred Wellman
entered the chat with a Savage ratio as
Fred explains in his tweet this is a TDY
a temporary Duty meaning it's a
short-term stay not a deployment like
Majewski falsely claims I was lucky
enough to chat with Fred on the phone
and he pointed something out to me that
I found very interesting the T ddy
document that Majewski shared online is
not even his it belongs to the staff
sergeant that he reported to at the time
so if you look at the document you'll
notice that Majewski has conveniently
blurred out the name at the top and
other details to make it seem like this
is his classified record and not only
that but while majuski was in the Air
Force he received a demotion for what he
claims was a dormitory brawl but
something tells me the real reason is
much worse especially since he was never
promoted after that incident and is not
allowed to re-enlist after being
discharged from the Air Force that's
suspicious
and if you look back at majewski's DD
Form 214 he doesn't have any medals that
are typically awarded to those who
served in combat in Afghanistan so now
we know Majewski doesn't have any medals
documents or let alone photos to prove
he was ever in Afghanistan majewski's
the kind of guy who tells you the same
War Story over and over again and when
you ask him questions about it he says
he can't say anything because it's G14
classified it's quite clear majewski's
been lying about his service for years
and now he's using those lies to prop
himself up as a candidate in the
Republican party however a day after the
AP story dropped the GOP cut all of
their funding for Majewski they canceled
nearly 1 million dollars in ads that
would help boost his campaign and with
the midterms around the corner Majewski
is all alone so now Majewski is just
trying to flood the Zone with frivolous
crap to distract people from talking
about his military experience or lack
thereof because at the end of the day he
doesn't have any well I'm Gabe San
Sanchez and this has been what was that
[Music]
okay as you all right what what was that
what was that what was that
okay there we go all right that's sorry
I'm trying to work the controls here I'm
trying to work the control too I just
want to point out for the fake Gabe that
is in the chat right now because he
wants to say oh it's not Stolen Valor
okay there are two uh there's I think
three requirements still or three
criteria you can hit for Stolen Valor
one is lying about because this is
actually a thing this isn't just like a
word they use this is an actual joke
it's not just thing this is a serious
this is a serious uh situation and so
Stolen Valor can be both you saying I
lied about your service right the other
one is is then taking the service and
and falsely claiming that you were in uh
tough or extreme conditions to make it
seem like you were more important than
it is to benefit from that from the
service that you did he falls within
that second criteria which is he claimed
and lied on multiple occasions that he
was deployed and served in combat in
tough conditions as he said in
Afghanistan and he was like I can't tell
you where I was blah blah blah the stuff
because it's classified at the end of
the day he lied about the service that
he did in when he was enlisted and and
here's the thing
he could have totally coasted by on just
saying I am a veteran I served in the
Air Force I did my time and I and I I I
served this country but that wasn't good
enough that was not good enough he had
to say oh no I gotta lie I gotta make it
seem better than what it is and there
are multiple multiple videos
in all of the videos that I showed there
are continuations of him talking to
interviews where he's like I don't want
to talk about it I don't want to go into
it and give too much detail it's not
really why would you why would you when
you're lying about it I mean when you're
standing when you're weird when you are
lying about uh your service you want to
probably keep it real tight on what
information you divulge and this is
someone who didn't feel like it was good
enough to just say I served in the Air
Force and I'm a proud veteran of the
United States of America that wasn't
good enough he had to then take it
further and lie about the service and
again I spoke with Fred Wellman on the
phone he broke down the TDY he broke
down the DD Form 214 he broke down the
actual service for me and explained how
this TDY is just a temporary State you
got put over somewhere for a short
period of time that wasn't actually
deployment you weren't serving there you
weren't in combat the other thing he
brought up to me was like he goes when I
when I went and served uh in uh after
2000 after 2001
I was I he's like I was taking photos I
was with friends I was in front of this
and I was front of that like I was in
front of the airport I took a photo
Majewski cannot produce one photo that
shows anything to say like oh we're in
Afghanistan right now he's got one photo
with some other people in what looks
like a little tunnel but there's no
identifying like information or details
to say oh that's the airport or oh
that's like this base or or hey look
that's that you know whatever location
the other thing I want to point out here
is he's saying the service is classified
if it's classified why is he talking
about it that's the other thing he's
giving away certain information to say
like oh yeah well it's classified so
you've already in a way that you served
in Afghanistan and you've served between
2002 2003
if this was classified you wouldn't be
going on TV that let alone sane
much there must be different standards
there must be a different standard for
Trump and his supporters handling
classified information then regular old
Americans and people who would normally
handle classified information it just
seems that way and uh fake gabier on
Facebook again we we pick on face fake
Gabe a little bit but you know here's
the thing we like fake Gabe because he
comes here every single day and he loves
to you know throw out the Trump talking
points the [ __ ] that he he gets in his q
and on Facebook groups I guess I don't
know where you're getting this stuff but
it really seems like you watched Tucker
Carlson just come on our chat and just
puke this stuff up
um because he says did I say that he did
say that you did say that the other day
fake Gabe you said it's not stolen
Valerie you said that I mean I can go
back in the chat and get the screenshot
and show you but really honestly you
know that's the game specifically today
which is him saying it wasn't Stolen
Valor
right and you know that's the case and
here's here is here is here's more proof
cite the law see here's the thing is
look I'm not in the business to do the
research for you I thought you people
love to do your own research so here's
what you can do pluck your head out of
your ass and go find the facts that you
need to have at your at your disposal or
you can just I don't know trust that
there are people out there that are
gathering up these facts that are
showing these facts to the public and
you can take those facts to to be that
you know this is basic stuff to know and
basic stuff to know what a TDY is and
that sort of thing of what people
reporting on and that's what you saw
with Gabe's little piece there is
reporting on what is happening now he
uses humor and he uses
um some little Clips here and there the
uh the Deep 14 classified is hilarious
by the way and then of course the cardi
B that's this vicious but here's the
thing vague game if if you would just
take a minute and realize that what
we're doing is not what is happening to
you on the right wing where they're just
feeding you for just a mountain a
mountain of Lies then you would
understand that it would be much easier
much easier for you to do your own
research and take what is fact use that
to couple yourself to reality and then
start at that point that's where you
that's a starting point but you are so
untethered from reality now hopefully
you coming watching every day helps you
with that process to get Tethered to
some sort of reality so that's I think
that's what Gabe is trying to do here
fake Gabe he's really not I'm just
trying to help you out I'm trying to
help you out I'm trying to break it down
in the simplest of terms because I know
a lot of people you know they they don't
have knowledge of the service they have
not served in the military that's why I
called Fred Wellman to actually break
this down and he did a great job of
explaining the key details especially
that TDY that it does not belong to uh
Majewski that actually belongs to the
group that Majewski was with at the time
and that specifically is for the staff
sergeant that he reported to hence why
like I said the names blurred out
there's other information that's blurred
out he made sure to keep Top Secret in
there well yeah well I mean I mean you
had to you had to make sure that it
seemed like what you were saying was
true I mean this is the trumpian way uh
let's bring David Minner and I think
he's finally got it David how are you
yeah well I'm I've sold all my Apple
stock
oh okay I got you well well you were
having a little technical difficulty but
I think you have an opinion on this
Majewski on this first off uh real game
let me compliment you that was a
terrific beat thank you um Marcy Kepler
who is the majiski's opponent was he's a
long-serving member of Congress he's a
great member of Congress and they cut up
her District so that a republican could
win it and almost any other Republican
would this guy is now toast because he
put himself in the toaster and and and
hit crisp uh so what what you've pointed
out here is that the entire National
Republican party has failed out of it
and they should because this is
something there there are a lot of lies
you can tell what's interesting you made
a point a moment ago uh Tony about the
the difference between
classification in Trump World and real
world
the fact is there are laws and this is
what's going to wind up catching up with
everybody when you violate the laws
there there are standards that can put
people in jail have many times uh and
and it happened to a Democrat some years
ago for something minor compared to what
we're seeing now so to to your point
this is all of a piece this is what the
standard now is there is nothing there
is no bar and with any great Good
Fortune what we're going to see coming
out of Mar-A-Lago what we're going to
see coming out of all of these cases is
the return of the rule of law
that's what democracy is based on and
there should be some Justice and Justice
is one of the things we can talk about
um I I don't know how are we on time
we've got about five minutes oh we get
it when no well we got we got plenty of
time we can we can extend okay then let
me let me let me go right into what we
would be talking about today which was
January 6.
um and I'm going to try and see if I can
get my non-apple uh unit here there we
go perfect God I'm almost to camera
um so so here's the deal
what happened was smart
uh you do not want to be competing for
national attention with a natural
disaster uh and so and one of the
members of Congress Stephanie Murphy is
from Florida so it made sense for them
to do this delay
one of the things we've also learned in
the last 24 hours
is this is going to give them more time
to go through Secret Service documents
that have been released now
um well and here's the funny part they
were released a while ago uh and they're
being overseen by a trump appointee
Joseph kaffari is the homeland security
Inspector General
he's got 24 cell phones of Secret
Service people he's had them since July
but the question is
is he sharing that information or is he
filtering that information there are a
lot of people who are very concerned
about kafari he's he's kind of like you
know uh homeland's version of the
Postmaster General
the Trump holdover who whose judgment
you can't really rely on to do the right
thing
but we do know that the committee has 8
000 of these documents and it's going to
take them time to process
and enough is going to get through uh
that's one of the things that we've seen
with The Meadows texts which started all
of this that we're we're gonna see a lot
of what happened from a secret service
perspective we may never get the texts
but there were email chains there were
Instagram posts there were things that
they shared with each other direct
messages that the committee now has and
however much time before and I'm
guessing it'll be Sometime Late next
week and that's a guess not a certain
date
uh until this next hearing
that's more time to build this case
and that's that is going to be very
powerful because it's going to detail
exactly what those agents witnessed it's
going to Bear out Cassidy Hutchinson
it's going to make a liar out of the
people who tried
to uh
say she was
misrepresenting the facts so this I'm
I'm not upset about this delay at all I
think it and and I will also agree with
you completely Tony that
uh we're about to see the rubber meet
the road uh you're a member of Florida
Governor Charlie crisp
uh was running again right now he was a
republican then and he posed with Barack
Obama he posed with him
and was driven out of his party
so if Joe Biden comes to Florida with
FEMA money
and DeSantis doesn't stand next to him
there's a real issue
because if the Biden White House says
this is I think they will they'll say
you know what this isn't about politics
right now they're talking but when when
that moment for the photo op comes it's
always the photo
uh that's when we're gonna see if
DeSantis
uh pisses off his base
or tries to act like a governor which
would be an act not a reality right so
that's that's where we are right now in
that Dynamic and we see that play out in
the next three four five days depending
on on uh the severity of the storm
so uh it's you're you're all safe right
no one's near Florida
I'm not in Florida no yeah I'm not near
Florida L.A well I I will I will I will
say the um
you know because it kind of seems like
this natural disaster this hurricane is
collided not just with Florida but also
with people's expectation of the January
6th select hearing some people are upset
that it's being postponed but you're
right I mean having having a member of
Congress that is on that committee
um and being a having constituents in
Florida I think that was the best
decision just because her resources her
staff's resources can now go towards
Floridians the way it should be I think
that's probably the most important point
of this The Narrative is also important
but I think that's probably the most
important point is that that Democrats
are serious you can see you know
Marjorie Taylor green operates
solely as a PR machine she has no
constituent service
and ironically that you know her people
don't seem to care they re-elect her but
the job of a member of Congress is to be
on the ground
when there's a need for your staff and
your assistants and that's what
Democrats do
and we're going to show it we you know
walking the talk means a lot and this is
that moment where you have to step up
you can't plan for these things I I
heard speaker Pelosi had an event about
two weeks ago
they we don't choose the times
the times choose us
and you know it's a simple concept but
right now these times and not just this
hurricane but democracy has chosen us
right now to stand up
and it's not a fight any of us wanted to
be in because it's a central fight
but we're in it right well I mean I mean
I I wish that uh Florida didn't have a
fascist Governor I mean that would be my
hope regardless if they're what party
they're affiliated with and I my hope is
is that eventually we can you know
either have a second an actual second
party that isn't fascist in this country
or we can get Republicans back on track
and get the the fascists to crawl back
underneath their rocks and that's really
was my goal in the a block today was to
get people understand that Rhonda Santos
is going to fail because he's not a
serious person he's not taking things
seriously and he's he has given no
evidence that he will take this
seriously when he's had other
manufactured crisis a real crisis is
something that is very difficult to deal
with and when you manufacture crisis to
deal with these things and to have this
political fodder where you're
dehumanizing people whether it be the
migrants from Venezuela that are
escaping a Communist Regime and coming
here seeking legal aside Asylum or
children in schools where he's
politicizing their genitalia and their
identities and even their damn Book
Fairs like this stuff is really
ridiculous and he's not a serious person
he really is not now he's serious he's
serious about implementing his fascist
beliefs on government and on the people
inside that make up that government
because that's the thing I keep telling
everyone we are the government the
people in Florida right now that are
bracing for this hurricane are the
government in Florida and guess what if
Rod DeSantis really wanted to be
Governor he would not watch us he's
going to
but the people of Florida get to
actually interview him and decide to
either rehire him or [ __ ] fire him
that is how this stuff works you don't
get to just subvert elections and not
have the people count and do all this
nonsense and be an unserious governor
and and have consequences so I hope that
the people of Florida will see that
um and I think as long as the people of
Lord engage in their democracy we will
have a governor in the State of Florida
that is serious about these issues just
like you pointed out Chris was serious
about this when he posted Obama even
though it killed his career in the
Republican party I brought that up and I
brought up uh Chris Christie as well
because it kind of did the same thing to
Chris Christie in New Jersey when Obama
came and and Christian said yes I want
the president's help to help my state
like that's the whole point he spent a
lot of time with him we walked the beach
with him he was really really active and
and actually in New Jersey it wasn't as
difficult as it is in Florida because
Florida is a complete Maga Republican
party right uh
I I will point out something I was
looking at your merch and the uh and I
get a smile out of Gabe immediately when
I say merch but the the the notion of
the t-shirt which says that uh the
senses should go
copulate with himself let me do the
polite thing here yeah sure that action
if executed would be something illegal
to talk about
in Florida
very good point frankly you'd be saying
that he's doing what you say you can't
say so I I think there's some irony
hidden irony in that shirt which I love
I am however going to get a pardon uh uh
company pardon blanket that looks really
really soft we need to actually put the
we need to put those in the merch store
somehow somewhere we need to put a part
in place yeah I mean it's like I said
it's it's it's very soft sheep wool uh
it will keep you warm from all those big
mean Democrats exactly right and more
and more are going to need those you
know I mean we have a list of maybe a
dozen right now but boy there were
probably more that we don't even know
about yet and I think we'll find them
out as these hearings go forward well
let's let's talk about the well go ahead
go ahead I was just gonna say the one
thing I want to add is is you know we
talk about you know Obama coming down to
Florida and like you know doing anything
that uh an empathetic human
president would do which is care for the
people that he represents the people
that even even care for the people that
did not vote for him right we know
Florida obviously is is represented as
heavily read debatable and actually how
that lays out it is a big Maga country
in terms of uh of of who they kind of
talk about and represent but I think the
big thing to remember here is something
you brought up which is like the real
leaders
in politics or just in life in general
are forged in crisis and how they
respond to said crisis is going to tell
you exactly who they are right and you
could say oh uh Ron DeSantis holding a
big check of money that came from the
government claiming even though they
voted against it and didn't want it but
then saying we got you this thing says
one thing but now
to see a to see a crisis
in a similar potentially hypocritical
fashion like we saw in Texas which is
you know Ted Cruz say no I don't want to
give New Jersey money but then saying
hey we need money down here and it's the
same thing that you'll probably see
DeSantis do whether or not he takes the
photo op there will be that like we're
not willing to help other people we're
very isolationist we only care about us
Republicans and I say that with very uh
liberal kind of uh definition there on
how much they care about their own party
but but seeing how Rod DeSantis will
react and if he takes a photo or accepts
that money or shakes his hand or
whatever he does with Biden I think
we'll be telling
um kind of like how you said and I think
it's very important that if he doesn't
that the president not in anger but in
sadness says you know uh I had invited
the governor here today I'm sorry he's
not here because this is not about
politics
and then move right on exactly but but
it cannot go unmentioned it can't
because then they'll do exactly what you
said they'll take credit for it I had to
be somewhere else because you know I was
dealing with a crisis it's all a lie
yeah but that's the important point of
how this goes we don't let them off the
hook and and Joe Biden is is out there
now being pretty tough on Mega
Republicans this moment it shouldn't be
politicized but it should not
go unnoticed and that's we'll see we're
about to say it in real time
um I and I know uh Tony you want to talk
about Denver riggleman speaking about uh
real time uh Denver riggleman for those
who don't think of him as a household
name uh he used to be a congressman from
Virginia Republican
uh and up until April he was on the
staff of the select committee in fact
Liz Cheney had uh purposefully tried to
recruit him as a former Republican
member adding credibility you know the
kinsinger herself riggleman was a staff
member seemed like a good call
uh
what has been very disappointing to the
committee
uh and including to his patronized
Chaney is that what he did was take
notes during that entire time
uh not tell anyone in fact lie wait a
minute a republican lied and said I'm
not writing a book uh oh wait yes I am
I'm writing uh about my work uh with
Ukraine
so I it just gets more and more
predictable now the book itself from
what I've seen I've only seen excerpts
uh is
does talk about you know some things
that allow a guy that no one's ever
heard of to sell books he's using inside
information about phone calls that went
from the White House switchboard to
possibly one of the capital uh rioters
uh he's talking about uh the cognitive
ability of Louis gohmert and Paul gosar
which is
you know not a long that's a one-line
sentence yeah actually it's one word
none uh but that's designed to promote
Book Sales
not to help the committee because the
committee has been unified in not
getting out ahead of its own message
and so it is disappointing to see
someone do that uh Tony where do you
when I disagree on that so I I think my
disagreement is this is that um because
we talk so much about people holding on
to information for books
um and I believe Denver riggleman could
have held on to this information for
much longer and profited a lot more off
this book I actually think Denver
riggleman is trying to in his own little
way damage trumpism because trumpism
kind of handed him uh his loss against
his Republican opponent he actually
um The Story Goes that if he wants the
60-minute interview he actually
officiated at one of his staffers
weddings and it they were gay and Q Anon
the Q Anon arm of the Republican Party
absolutely 100 percent made it into that
he was some kind of
part of the Democrat blood-sucking cabal
because he he actually humanized the
lgbtq community and which is which is
not off brand it's totally on brand for
trumpism
um but but they absolutely dealt him uh
a blow in his primary and I think he had
a little bit of Vengeance in him
probably for that and I think that's one
thing and and so so I agree with you on
that maybe Denver riggleman's aim was
not for the select committee exactly or
the investigation itself I believe maybe
he was the right person because some of
the things in that interview that he has
uncovered with this data and his team
uncovered and he was kind of waving his
arms up and down in the committee saying
hey this is important stuff and they
weren't really willing to
um focus on that as much which again we
can debate rather that is a good thing
for the select committee or not because
you're getting into the weeds with data
which Americans will not pay attention
to so we can debate that point but I
think
one point that was back in April we
don't know if they got into that data
from April forward you know we're in
September right so right
he's dated about the data right and
again I think I think my disagreement is
that is that riggleman
um holding this information
um instead of releasing the book now I
think releasing the book now regardless
of his motivations is better than worse
for the American people to know this
information
um now whether it's coordinated with the
select committee I will give you an
agreement there that you know maybe
their plan to release this information
was a little more coordinated and would
have been a better narrative but at the
same time we are barreling in and and
I'll tell you the American people who
are sick and tired of watching these
criminals run around free when we know
what they've done we know we just don't
have every single piece of evidence but
we know the select committee does we
know the doj does these Americans are
getting frustrated and I I feel their
frustration but I also know that there
is time and there is a process and there
is an effort to make sure these people
are prosecuted at the very top to the
highest extent of the law but also
um I I believe that if if we don't get
out in front of this and politicize this
which we are
um before the election it could be that
a republican house could do all sorts of
weird things now the law is the law like
you said that'd be fund the justice
department
well I mean or or well I mean again the
law is the law so then they do have
their arms around appropriation
um but it it is a thing that they can
jam up government and they can jam up
this investigation but again if if we if
we have to know the stakes and I think
Denver riggleman's outside his profit
for his book because that is kind of a
little gross but when you when you
consider the information that you're
delivering for the American people that
hey this was a huge operation and it was
very few people who were organizing it
it because I think that's the thing that
gets lost a little bit in this in this
idea of this committee uh and even even
the narrative in the country is that all
these were all individuals and it was
thousands of people and they were
listening to Social Media no it was six
about six groups of people who were
organizing this narrative and we're
organizing this rally and getting these
people riled up to come and do what they
did
um there's new footage this morning
David of at these uh the the
insurrectionists the people on the
ground uh actually using the flag Bulls
to beat cops and also they used a big
huge Trump Banner with a big huge metal
frame around it as a battering ram to
tear down the barricades um we've seen
this video in a time lapse version from
a camera high up on the Capitol building
which is very it's a very weird ominous
uh part of our history now to see that
time lapse video but now we see it in
body cams from the police officer's
point of view
and the and and watching these
insurrectionists these violent
insurrectionists actually using this
thing as a battering ram to try to not
only damage the the barrier that was
keeping them from going into the capital
but also harm the law enforcement
officers so there's new footage of that
and we're going to play that here and
I'm running out of time but one thing I
want to ask you about is last time we
were here you had that little that
little dog how is the little dog doing I
think we we I think you called her Falla
when when we were here he's the boy okay
named after uh FDR's dog whose full name
was Murray The Outlaw of Fowler Hill uh
he's a Scottish uh Warrior uh that uh
and I think Murray was a little bit of a
Jewish name for for the time so FDR went
with fella but it's actually you know
Justice is is both Global and local
and and we've had a rough experience I I
rescued that dog and he was with me and
I think you've got a picture of him
um the he was
not in great shape a Yorkie 18 months
old very scared
brought him into our family uh
it started to get him adjusted he
started going out on walks he was
getting happy he sat for an interview uh
on this program uh and did great
defending democracy
uh it turned out they didn't tell us
that he had ringworm they didn't test
for it they could have it's a normal
protocol that they just missed
and everybody got including the dog who
had it ringworm
so this is an organization that I had
worked with before and thought did good
work but now uh there's
there's Murray and I don't know how he
is
I don't know uh if we're going to get
them back they are not taking
responsibility for uh that action and uh
you know I'm gonna ask people if they
love Justice and love
love that little dog as much as I do and
it's hard to not look at him and not
know how special he is
um help me find out
how's how is my dog I can't get an
answer
uh it's info at
wagsandwalks.org info at
wagsandwalks.org
if any of you out there can say how is
Murray bender and is David getting him
back
um you know I think they are
being concerned about their own
reputation rightfully so but I I I only
want the dog I I want him safe I want
him back as part of our family
and that is as important to me as
anything could be
um along with the fate of democracy
which very seriously so so info anyone
out there
so so Gabe's probably going to put the
um the uh link here in the chat for
anyone who wants to go and inquire so
we're just I think David's asking
politely for you just to go and say hey
how is Murray he's not able to check on
Murray he wants to see Murray again
Murray uh visit us with us on this
episode
um and this video is actually on YouTube
David bender on the fate of democracy
you can go to our YouTube channel and
you can see little Murray there
um when as he was on our interview for
the Tony Michaels podcast but everyone
go go see if you can find out for David
it would be much help to him he loves
his little dog he wants his dog back but
he's most worried about how the dog is
doing I think is your biggest concern
and you just want to know how he's it
makes sure he's safe right David and
just think and I want to make sure that
they will commit that he is coming back
to us yes um and just for the just for
the listeners this is for the Los
Angeles location correct it is correct
it's the Los Angeles location
uh there's a phone number
866-588-9247
location for Wags and walks info Wags
and walks uh you know the people who
work there are wonderful people and they
do good work this was an unfortunate
circumstance but at the end of the day
the right thing to have happen is I want
to take care of my dog
sure
so with we can we can it's often said
that you know you fight the battles
globally but you have to fight them
locally too
and this is about Justice
for Murray so I appreciate very much
anyone who can help the inquiries will
move the dial the inquiries will get
people to respond to me in ways that
I've been unable to do it in any now
three weeks so I'm grateful to both of
you for uh your kindness and giving me
the opportunity as they'd say in
Congress it's a point of personal
privilege uh well it's a privilege it's
a privilege having you here David and
and again the audience David is asking
for a polite inquiry uh to the to the to
the shelter there just seeking if he's
going to be coming home soon and if he's
safe and sound and happy that's what
David wants to know
and getting recovering in the critium uh
again please polite not mean but but
very direct uh Marie Murray Bender
in Fort Wags and walks dot org
listen guys we have a lot more that
we're going to be talking about and as
soon as we get a date
uh for this hearing I'll say one more
thing about the hearings
yeah it's been said that this is going
to be the last one and it's the morning
uh it was scheduled for this morning
right now
uh I don't believe that I personally I
don't have proof of it but every
Instinct I have in and conversations
I've had privately tell me that what is
likely to happen
is that some more information not Jenny
Thomas that's the sideshow but more
information like the Secret Service
information some other things uh you
know the Roger Stone video Whatever It
Is
uh and perhaps a witness that we don't
yet know another Cassidy Hutchinson high
level Witness
will wind up being the last
and that will be in prime time
and that's what we want we want this to
your point we want the American people
to see this evidence
including some of what Denver rigelman
has talked about in prime time they need
to tie it together
uh the Insurrection uh the series
did very well initially people were
skeptical that the American people would
watch
they're watching and the last one the
networks haven't been covering uh they
will if it's in prime time so that's
that's the other thing we need to press
for and encourage and I believe will
happen
well I appreciate you joining us David I
can't wait for for them to reschedule
this so we get it on the calendar so
that way we can get back at the business
of you called it Insurrection season two
I call it season two treason Hunters uh
David Bender thanks for joining us as
always you're welcome back anytime yes
go ahead anything else I'm just saying
thank you and thank you again for for my
point of personal privilege and for for
help but in reuniting my family and my
dog absolutely everyone go give a plight
inquiry about Murphy
Murray Bender sorry
Murray it's the Murray vendor see that's
where I'm getting confused that's
probably where I'm getting confused I
used to watch that show when I was a kid
David Bender thanks for joining us as
always you are welcome here on the Tony
Michaels podcast we'll see you soon my
friend everyone stick around we'll be
right back with this with the shitless
round up right after this break stick
around
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
we gotta do a fast round of shitless
Roundup
I think Gabe's gonna cut out on Saturday
unless you talk him out of it I don't
think he can talk him out of it I think
he's got some meetings he's got to go to
or something but Gabe I think we got
about we know we got about 15 20 minutes
is that what we got here we got 20
minutes 20 minutes and 20 minutes okay
so we're gonna do the shitless Roundup
here did you ever watch this um the
footage of the um the banner coming
across the crowd at the Capitol and
using it as a battering Ramen no no no
okay so this is this is a shot
um from the police officer's perspective
which I think is probably the most
interesting perspective body cam footage
well when you consider the people who
were carrying back the blue flags and
beating the cops with him I think it's
the most interesting perspective really
honestly
um and and again it just it's so crazy
that we even have to if we even have to
[ __ ] do this because this is part of
American history that when we look back
30 or 40 years from now people who who
consider people who even supported Trump
are going to be like what in the [ __ ]
were these people thinking just like
just like people now look at Germany in
1930s and 1940 singing what the [ __ ]
were those people thinking well to some
degree it is delusional and they're not
they're just they're just not thinking
it through and they're not operating
with the full set of the facts so let's
do this I want to give you the facts I
want to show you this video because we
should not look away no matter how bad
it is for our democracy that happened
and what happened is bad we need to know
that it's bad so we do not have this
happen future we can prevent it and why
it's so important that you engage in
your democracy not just be complacent in
it so let's do this let's go to the [ __ ]
let's round up let's round up the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
about the Tweety tweets and training
Trends and give you the facts
on the shitless Roundup here's the first
video of this uh there are several
different perspectives here Ryan Reilly
actually uh posted these videos this one
is of a gentleman beating a
I can't even believe this is uh I'm sure
a back the blue guy and the reason why
is because this gentleman here who's
gonna be swinging the flagpole at the
police officer game his son
is apparently a police officer watch
this little footage here
[Applause]
okay
so this narrative out there that this
was not a violent attack from Trump
supporters is absolutely ridiculous this
video right here proves it through and
through this is a [ __ ] body cam
footage video from the police officer's
perspective on the other side of this
barricade which they were trying to
protect the capital and trying to
protect our government from and here you
have an older gentleman who obviously is
a trump supporter with a [ __ ] Flag in
his hand beating the [ __ ] out of law
enforcement officials now I I have to
say one thing if this guy who's swinging
this flank pool was a [ __ ] black dude
he would be dead number one and that is
one thing I think is lost on this
Insurrection [ __ ] that a bunch of these
[ __ ] white people running up and
committing violence because you see
there you see it looks like there's a
person of color standing next to this
white guy he ain't got a flag in his
hand swinging it and I wonder why but
this white this old white man I'm gonna
I'm gonna mute it play this again here
he is swinging the flag violently
beating the cop
he's not swinging it against you know
the the barrier he's swinging and
hitting the [ __ ] officer in the face
here I mean here's the thing like this
is something that you would look at and
say
uh would I even want to treat some like
think of the the situation of where you
would normally do that where you would
normally beat someone with an object and
say that's okay and this situation
specifically you have law enforcement
that Capitol Police there to protect the
capital they're doing their job
then you've got this guy who decides oh
well you know what I deserve to go into
that [ __ ] building and let those
lawmakers know exactly what I have to
say and the person that's standing in my
way is the person that's doing their job
again Capitol Police protecting the
Capitol building
so he beats him
in what other scenario because this is
not okay this is not acceptable whether
you're any of these people on the Maga
side or you've got fake Gabe in the
comments being like was this an
Insurrection this is unacceptable you
cannot tell me after looking at this
video oh yep you know what that old man
should have totally beat that cop that
is unacceptable that is an unacceptable
excuse for you to say uh in this one
scenario this is totally okay it's never
[ __ ] okay what happened to back the
blue what happened to protecting those
who protect our streets Serve and
Protect that you're telling me that that
it's okay for this guy to get mad at
this cop for doing his job he's there
just holding a barricade and you're like
yeah you know what it's actually
perfectly fine that they try to use a a
flagpole a weapon a metal object to beat
them
this is something that again is a
completely unacceptable there's no
reason there's no excuse for it there's
no way to justify it
it is it is flat out wrong
unacceptable
and a crime
right well that's the thing that a lot
of people are missing here is that these
things that they're doing are crimes and
they're federal crimes because they're
doing them on federal property
committing them against the Capitol
Police who are federal police officers
this is really this is really stupid
stuff that these people were doing
including this video now again this is
from one of the Vantage points of the
officer standing at this barricade now
from what I understand this is a
different body cam than the body cam we
just saw this is in the same vicinity
and location but watch how they move
this Banner you can't really see it here
in the video it's kind of back here
behind this guy's shoulder they're
carrying it they're kind of crowd
surfing it I guess you would say now in
the video like I said the time lapse
video that they released several weeks
ago and Ryan's the one who put it on his
Twitter and I actually put the two
videos together and put it on our
YouTube so you could see it as one long
video and you can go to our YouTube
channel
uh and actually watch it there so don't
forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel while you're there but you can
watch it
um it's in the clips playlist and it's
the it's the Insurrection time lapse
video you can find it pretty easy there
but in that time lapse video Gabe
because the the vantage point is from so
far up it looks like they're just
they're like crowd surfing a banner like
you would a flag across the football
field you know what I'm talking about
like at halftime or doing the first part
of the show where they're doing the
national anthem that's what it looked
like in the time lapse video but in this
video it is much different it is much
different what happened because what is
surrounding that Banner is this big huge
heavy what seems to be aluminum of some
sort of metal frame with big huge wheels
on the bottom and they're using it as a
as a battering ram to not only Ram the
barricade but the police officers that
are standing in front of them because
they want to go and overthrow our
government that's what they're trying to
do here so watch as as this barrier gets
hauled across here and I'm gonna play
the sound first so you can hear it
because they're acting wild here and you
can see this guy standing up front just
um getting in the officer's faces but
watch
here comes the banner yeah that is
great and you can see it's got a large
base
[Applause]
thank you
okay so there's the video with the sound
and I'm gonna play it a few times here
without the sound
um so you can keep looking at it here as
we're talking about this video because
here's the thing
this this idea that this was not a
violent Insurrection and they weren't oh
well the cops LED them through I mean
there were instances where the cops were
running them through barriers but the
cops were defending their position to
defend our government folks now if you
watch in this video it looks like the
the police officers do a fairly decent
job of stealing away this battering ram
away from the crowd but I'm gonna show
you another video here soon that shows
they were a bit successful to some
degree and if you go watch that time
lapse video because when you watch that
part about the banner it looks really
strange right when it happens because
it's like why the what the banners kind
of you know stretched out and weird in
that in that bit time lapse video the
reason why it's because it's on a frame
it's on a frame and it seems to float
across the crowd in the time lapse video
very easily and now we know it's because
it's on a frame see when you when you
get new facts Gabe when you get new
facts and new information it really does
change your perception of something now
the video the time lapse video is really
[ __ ] weird even even without this
perspective but I want to bring
something up here uh fake Gabe
um
uh believes that uh being armed with a
flagpole means you can take over the
country or that a flagpole is a weapon
of War
or what the U.S armed forces cannot
defend the onslaught of a sole flagpole
here's the thing fake Gabe
what you have seen and what you you
clearly know you know that it's wrong
you know that as we play more videos in
the video that Tony's about to play it's
going to prove that comments like this
are dumb ignorant and and make you
honestly like
it kind of makes us question the reality
that you live in what everything you say
everything you say I mean anything you
bring to the table I have to go well
fake Gabe is full of [ __ ] because I
automatically go he can't even he can't
even adhere to a certain set of facts
and a certain set of truth that you we
we re we uh assume yeah that you're
completely decoupled from reality
um is the problem right and that's the
problem that trumpism has in this
country and it's gonna really have when
the electorate decides to punish it
again we punished it back in 2020 by 8
million people more people voting for
Joe Biden than Trump like that was the
hey it's time to cut it out that was
like your sign that was your signal that
you're full of [ __ ] [ __ ] and the
country doesn't want your nonsense and I
believe in this 2020 election because a
lot of political pundits are like oh
Democrats are gonna let no they're not
no they're not this country is sick and
[ __ ] tired of trumpism and people who
[ __ ] are deluded with it they are
[ __ ] sick and tired they're sick and
tired they may even be Republicans and
conservatives and be pro-life and
they're sick and tired of the dumb ass
down the street with all these flags all
stupid [ __ ] bumper stickers yelling
and screaming about Trump one and all
this [ __ ] just nonsense they're sick
of the [ __ ] nonsense they're tired of
it they're tired of it and and and one
example is someone sycophanting for this
crowd just being tourists are just there
because they're Patriots no they're not
they're [ __ ] Traders watch this video
here because Gabe this video this
perspective again it's in the same type
of position at this at this barricade
that that law enforcement is trying to
hold here to protect our government and
you'll watch as the banner moves across
the crowd in this footage but again this
is another law enforcement officer's
body Cam that this perspectives from but
Watch What Happens watch how this crowd
is actually trying to use this against
the barricade and the cops because this
does a much better job because this
officer is standing he's one of the
people who they were trying to use it
against watch this video
here you see the banner moving across
the crowd with the big wheels
[Applause]
they moving into place here to move it
forward to use a battery Rim they're
coordinating
you notice the barriers are broken down
so people try to get through
[Applause]
officers quickly reassembled to try to
hold back the crowd
now again
this is another example of why people
like fake Gabe are completely [ __ ]
wrong this was a violent Insurrection
your orange Mussolini Jesus used lies to
convince all these dumb [ __ ] to
show up and overthrow the government in
his name that is what they were there to
do now regardless if they believe the
lies or not it doesn't matter the people
who drove them there for these lies and
to overthrow our democracy is what
[ __ ] matters and you're one of them
get fake Gabe you're one of them because
you keep perpetuating the [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] and again I know we it feels
like we pick on fake gabier but I
actually uh I admire fake gate for
coming here every single day
and listening to us because I know
eventually fake Gable probably see the
light he'll pluck his head out of his
ass and he'll realize that what he's
been saying is ridiculous stuff
the reason I you know I wanted to bring
it up today with him on there for two
reasons one is through the what was that
segment to call out the misinformation
or just the lack of ability to accept
the facts that are there which is like
J.R Majewski
uh you know Stolen Valor and in this
example right here you want to say oh
the police or the U.S armed forces can't
defend against a single flagpole that's
not a single flagpole and the fact that
you want to use this to say oh look
that's just a big flag on a metal a
frame right wheels that weighs probably
something that's a decent amount of
weight especially if it's used to go at
force with enough people toward a group
well I would love to know what were they
using that if it wasn't as a weapon what
were they using it for right I would
love to hear the explanation from fake
Gabe or another Mega Republican to
justify how using an object like this
that is that large what were they using
it for if it wasn't to get through and
force the cops and those who are on
defense
against the way to attack them if it
wasn't used for that what was it used
for
well here's the other thing too the
about his statement that's [ __ ]
really stupid is he says the U.S armed
forces right the problem is the problem
is is that the White House didn't want
to deploy the National Guard they didn't
want to and the reason why is because
they knew that the National Guard would
do a job that the that the Capitol
Police was would struggle to do that's
what they knew that's why they didn't
deploy them fake Gabe is because they
were trying to overthrow our democracy
unconstitutionally he was trying to be
dictator and King because he wants to
rule over you and the fact remains Gabe
that he [ __ ] hates you he [ __ ]
hates you he loves that you sycophant
for him he loves that you love that you
that you wipe the Cheeto dust off your
mouth for him but he [ __ ] hates you
he he despises all these people he
wouldn't he wouldn't stand within 10
feet of these people who showed up to
the Capitol with him not within 10 feet
and just because he's Trump and just
because Trump is on stage kissing and
making out with a [ __ ] Flag like it's
his wife because clearly wasn't giving
the attention it is gross right it is a
gross representation of what our
presidency was to go up and go
kiss that flag and then you've got these
guys and they're like oh well anytime
somebody touches a flag Tony it's
clearly because they mean it out of love
that is what fake game and probably all
these other mag Republicans believe is
that anytime you touch a flag it's meant
out of care and love and romance and
definitely not used as a weapon or a
battering ram to go against the police
the capital police to get into a
building to try to overthrow a
government or take lawmakers hostage or
hang the vice president or whatever they
said you know
different game and everyone else it's
not a crime it was totally made out of
love we were punching those people and
beating them because we love them
right well it is the it is the trumpism
logic here it is the good liars always
do such a great job of showing this
right out of trumper's mouth and um this
this video proves it right here this is
the logic that fake Gabe gives this is
the logic that they've been giving for
the videos that I just showed you trying
to act like it's antifa or it's oh it
was just tourists they weren't violent
they were there patriotically and all
this nonsense listen to what this lady
says about choice and freedom of choice
and then the the Dismount here Gabe is
beautiful and then we gotta let you go
but let's listen yeah just like the
vaccine they tried to mandate on me if
it's my body my choice for them it
should be for me too so you're saying it
is your body your choice
a choice you're saying for the vaccine
it's your it is your body your choice
yes well I'm saying both ways if you you
know they want to cry oh just get the
vaccine get the vaccine your body it
doesn't matter you know but now it's on
the other shoes on the other now that
abortion is illegal in certain States
across the country would you be okay
with a vaccine mandate no did you get
vaccinated okay so you did not comply
with the Mandate okay but you do feel
that if if a woman uh is pregnant that
she should go along with the Mandate in
that state to have the baby yes okay
foreign
hypocritical probably but I mean this is
trumpism this is trumpism in a nutshell
basically hey I
hey I don't believe in mandates mandates
bad government mandates bad I won't do
because actually there was no mandate it
was actually a choice it was just
requirements at certain jobs that you
had to have it wasn't a mandate they
weren't holding you down and forcing you
now they do hold you down and force you
to have babies in some states now even
if it's a dead baby inside of you
they'll force you to bring someone who
violated you right through rape held you
down and violated right so this lady it
just is trumpism right out in the open
is walking trumpism it's walking
hypocrisy and I know you have to go on
us here but um
Gabe it just it's not surprising and
that's why I that's again that's why we
bring fake game in every day because
he's here and he he he gives us a good
Insight our audience a good insight and
absolute garbage that these people
consume and believe and dilute
themselves with
um and that is how we fight this folks
is not ignore it we cannot ignore this
stupid [ __ ] we have to give it Daylight
it is the best disinfectant and you can
come join us every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right here
on YouTube Twitter twitch for two full
hours well some of us do full hours
I
I you know
what I will say is if fake Gabe wants to
sub in for me right now
I would love to see that debate happen
oh while I'm while I'm going yeah I I
would I would imagine it would be a
tough thing for tough road for fake age
so everyone everyone even though Gabe is
leaving us fake Gabe staying here I
don't know maybe that says something uh
you've never thought they gave a real
game in the same room together right
that's true that's true that may be it
ah [ __ ] go follow David on Twitter at I
am Gabe Sanchez Gabe thanks for joining
us buddy
um see you tomorrow maybe for the whole
show I don't know I'll be here for the
whole show all right have a good one
have a good one have a good meeting
we'll talk to you guys then bye
everybody thanks for sticking around
let's let's do this because I get um
another video I want to show you here
um Tucker Tucker schmecker Carlson uh
where is it where is it and and Tulsi
gabbard this is oh this is a beautiful
piece of content and again this is goes
right at you can't look away these
[ __ ] boneheads
here is a Tucker Carlson on White
Privilege tonight on Fox News
with Tulsi gabbard sickle fanting for
Putin now this has been an ongoing thing
you know that that Tucker Carlson's head
is all the way up Putin's ass I'm not
sure exactly uh how much the Putin
checks are they must be way more than
the George Soros chicks you know I mean
there's the Deep State George Soros
checks that we all receive all those lip
tards get oh you're just paid by George
Soros to say this stuff so why can't I
assume if that's the case that you
project your [ __ ] onto me why can't
I assume that Tucker Carlson has his
head so far up Putin's ass that he can
taste what he had for lunch
um because my guess is is that Tulsi and
Tucker here are receiving some sort of
kickback
from their their Master their Master
Putin
um listen to this nonsense here about
this Pipeline and the rupture in this
Pipeline and how they want it to start
nuclear war literally they're calling
for it here listen if it turns out that
the Biden Administration actually blew
up a natural gas pipeline or okayed
someone else's sabotage of that pipeline
shouldn't there be a federal law that
prevents them from lecturing the rest of
us about climate change ever again
okay so here he's saying the United
States government
um killed this Pipeline and the reason
why he's saying that is because the
Russians said it okay the Russians said
that we did this thing which almost
immediately this is the same type of
thing when you when fake Gabe is putting
something in the Facebook comment you
have to automatically believe that it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] just because it's
coming out of his account like he's
typing it in on his feed right anything
that the Russian government says or
Putin says or RT Russian TV whatever
wherever the [ __ ] it's coming from or
Anna Tucker's mouth through Putin's
[ __ ] through Tucker's mouth here
that it's complete utter [ __ ] and
then pile on top of that the Putin's
sycophant Tulsi gabbard the Russian
asset that is Tulsa gabbard here
um confirming that yes it is nonsense
because I believe everything the
Russians say again the reason why
they're saying this nonsense on Fox news
that Trader TV news network is because
Russia said it so they automatically
believe Russia and Putin if you can
believe it
that's why they're saying the United
States did this and all at the same time
he has to really go balls deep into the
fascism where he wants to have a law
where he does not have to listen to
science and fact he wants a law to where
we do not allow people to talk about
science in fact that's literally what he
said let's continue
with the Putin's puppet
I I don't have the evidence of who was
responsible for this oh really Tulsi
gabbard has no evidence of who was
responsible for this but
and there's a big one she's gonna
believe Putin because
Putin gives a great paycheck apparently
uh there there will be consequences if
that is ever found out but we have the
reality of what we're dealing with right
before us today which is if we continue
down this path we may end up with a
nuclear Holocaust and so for us and for
millions of people around the world what
are we going to do about it we've got to
call on our leaders to actually take a
stand and fight for peace fight for
Prosperity fight for our future
and that is exactly what the world and
the United States is doing you dumbass
is they're fighting the [ __ ] tyranny
of Vladimir Putin a murderous [ __ ]
dictator trying to take over a sovereign
democracy crossing a border and trying
to overthrow at another country its own
Sovereign democracy when they clearly do
not want Russians there
and Tulsi gabbard is buying the Putin's
propaganda Hook Line and Sinker which I
mean she doesn't really buy it
it's all [ __ ] they know it's all
[ __ ] [ __ ] they know it is they
know it is
and they're stoking they're stoking the
the possibility of having nuclear war
they're like oh we should stop this
playing footsie with nuclear war then
stop spreading [ __ ] Russian
propaganda
about what the United States is and
isn't doing you [ __ ] idiots
if you want to prevent any kind of war
or you want to Tamp down war and have
peace maybe you should be on the side of
Peace which is what Ukraine wants they
wants to peacefully sovereignly have a
democracy
that's what they want that's what they
wanted and they told Putin we are going
to fight if you come here we are going
to fight for our country we're going to
fight for our democracy because we want
our democracy and we want peace you do
not bring peace you are a you are a
dictator you are a murderous piece of
[ __ ] you are scum you are an
authoritarian and that does not equal
peace
authoritarianism does not equal peace
and that is the decision that we must
lay before our electorate here in the
United States in this most important
election of our democracy's lifetime
the 2022 midterm is you have a choice
you have a choice for peaceful discourse
and and peaceful democracy and vote for
pro-democracy candidates which the only
side that had pro-democracy candidates
right now are the Democrats
or you can vote for authoritarianism and
Crown Donald Trump a fascist dictator of
a murderous [ __ ] he wanted to
bomb Mexico folks he wanted to bomb
Mexico
he locked people in cages
he wanted to shoot people as they were
coming across the border
and he's cheering when they use humans
as political props
listen
he wants to he wants to execute drug
dealers
your your person that owns a dispensary
the marijuana dispensary he wants to
give them the death penalty sounds are a
pro-life to me okay
so your choice is democracy
or autocracy
authoritarianism
or we the people what are you gonna
choose and you have the choice to engage
in your democracy now right now you can
check your registration have your
friends check the registration go get
people registered to vote if you still
can in your state
make sure you're talking about these
issues with your friends your family
your community it is so important
and it's happening all over the country
folks it's happening
I'm telling you people are tired and and
sick of this nonsense
of trumpism they're absolutely sick of
the [ __ ]
and I got a video to prove it to you
here is um Donald Trump Jr and his guard
girl I mean Kimberly gilfoyle excuse me
um at a turning points USA event now
this is a Charlie Kirk turning points
USA event
these people are booing the [ __ ] out of
them watch how they freak out
when there's dissent on them
damn she is happy to answer a question
I guess that's the normal course for for
Kimberly gargoyle I mean gilfoyle when
she yeah
yelling into the microphone I mean I
don't blame everyone in the microphone I
do it every day but this is a little
weird they have a little bit of a
descent
and they just don't like it when there's
descent and the room turns on them watch
this
lies lies
lies
no
dispute they said well we like the jobs
see here you are
here it is here's the moment where
they're booed off stage
[Applause]
listen it should be an Unwritten rule in
this country
an Unwritten and unspoken rule really
but I gotta speak it it's ridiculous
that we have to speak it but it should
be an Unwritten rule that we boo
traitors
should be a [ __ ] rule if you're a
traitor you should expect to be booed
especially off a [ __ ] stage
that's how it should get and we should
get loud and we should get proud
because the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
it says it in the beginning folks every
day the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty
it's time to engage in your democracy
fight
for Liberty everyone's Liberty not just
yours but everyone's Liberty not for an
authoritarian state where they tell you
what religion who you can and can't
marry
what clothes you can and can't dress in
what books you can and can't read
it is time for democracy not
authoritarianism and we can tell them to
go get [ __ ] you have that unique
opportunity and that opportunity is
going to be present it to you
this year the midterm in just over a
month
and if you're ready
get ready and if you aren't ready get on
board
and also lean into it
lean into it don't just use the power of
your ballot use the power of your voice
you can use the power of your voice come
here every single weekday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter
and twitch follow us on YouTube
subscribe we'll give you the power every
day to go out and yell and scream follow
us on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you
can go follow us on Twitch as well and
also download every single episode Apple
Spotify Google we give you the narrative
we give you the message we will pound it
out into their brains also go to Tony
Michaels dot live
and follow us there support Independent
Media we run on your support here at the
Tony Michaels podcast we run on your
support rather that's through retweets
are you guys watching sharing commenting
commenting on the live chat rather be on
Facebook twitch or YouTube
we run on your support so go to
tonymichaels.live you can leave a tip
there a one-time tip or you can set it
up to do it monthly so you don't have to
you don't have to think about it it just
does it you can also go to our merch
store
store.thetonymichaels.com you can get
doubt me merch and go get Rhonda santis
can go [ __ ] himself coffee mug boy those
are getting hot the coffee mugs
let's say Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ]
himself but the hottest the hottest one
we got is the dark Brandon merch so go
to store.d Tony michaels.com
and get all your merch there rather be
dark Brandon Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ]
himself get you a [ __ ] sticker as
well there you know we used to have the
old logo the let's talk logo a lot of
people have been ordering that sticker
that sticker's getting more and more
popular inside the merch store go check
out all the merch at store.d Tony
michaels.com you can also go to Tony
Michaels dot Live support us there we
run on your support and if you click the
little sandwich icon the little
hamburger icon at the top it'll lead you
to if you want to [ __ ] them hat there's
the store there the merch store you can
go you can go to the listen tab that
will take you to all the places where
you can actually listen and download
our podcast every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific live right here on YouTube
Twitter and twitch and simulcasting to
the Midas touch Facebook page
I'm glad you were with us today I'm so
happy you're with us even though we
didn't get to have the hearing and I
want to say everyone in Florida and and
everyone tell MJ she's one of our
moderators tell her to be safe she's in
Florida but everyone in Florida all the
Floridians no matter your your ideology
no matter your party no matter your
citizenship status be safe be very very
safe we want everyone to come on the
other side of this storm and be safe
same time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
thank you
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon